and the lobby of Ramsey solutions Kelly
is with us hi Kelly how are you I'm
great how are you better than I deserve
welcome where do you live I live in
DeForest Wisconsin just outside Madison
Oh fun
very cool welcome to Nashville so you're
here to do your debt-free scream I sure
AM I love it how much have you paid off
I paid off fifty two thousand two
hundred thirty-eight dollars and 67
cents I love it way to go kiddo and how
long did that take you
it took 23 months making what kind of
money the take home was about 2,800 a
month to 3,700 a month roughly so was
55,000 a year
yeah the take home was about that yeah
okay well no the take home would be less
than that but I mean you're gross should
be about 55 a year thicker the gross was
it started at about 60 yeah okay all
right very cool what do you do for a
living I am an air traffic controller
good for you awesome okay well I'll make
sure I fly carefully when I'm coming
into Madison all right good that's fun
so what kind of debt was the 52,000 some
of it I had about 21,000 in student
loans about just under 20,000 for truck
payment and then a consolidation loan
from you know thinking I was going to
work on it earlier I'm gonna borrow your
way out of debt that's right and then a
credit card so tell me the story what
happened 23 months ago well you may
remember the shutdown talk the talk of
the government shutdown and the
furloughs and all of that and I realized
that even just missing the one day was
freaking me out and eventually you know
they decided that we were essential and
we had to go anyways but that meant we
didn't get paid until they had the money
to pay us so there was that that I work
for free yeah that's right oh yeah yeah
I realized that was really close and I
was just like so I was calling everybody
I was like it's gonna be late it's gonna
be late
and then somebody else retired and a few
months after that and he just seemed so
at ease he wasn't worried about it and
we have to retire early he was gonna
live another 30 years and had to live
off his retirement I was like I want to
be that guy so I had I got scared and I
got a goal there you go and then I
jumped on it I liked it great story
very cool and so at that point you got
the motivation you got you got the fear
and the the positive motivation from the
retirement guy that's very cool and then
what happened what'd you do
well I had heard of the I had heard of
you in 2006 when I was still in college
and kind of dabbled in it throughout the
years so then I just I finally I sat
around I was like alright what am I
gonna do and then I was debating and I
had just bought the truck ten months ago
oh so I traded it whoa
and I got that basically knocked $5,000
off the debt but I also drive 83 miles
to work one way so it saved me about
$400 a month and gas and there was my
wiggle room so between the payment and
the gas and okay should you get a hold
of the total money makeover Booker you
just did it from listening the radio or
what well I had gotten the the book back
in 2006 when she told me about it and I
got really obsessed right then I just
didn't implement any of it I got you and
so I knew that and then once I started
working the plan I really I started
listening on I heart because I had a
long commute I could listen to most of
the show and that was pretty much what I
did was the book in the and the radio
perfect very good that's neat well
congratulations
so now you're that person like that guy
that I hired I wanna be that guy that
retired he was calm cool collected he
had control of his money now you're that
person it's a little different subject
but you've paid off all your debt you
paid off fifty-two thousand dollars
worth of debt so now a friend a
co-worker of family members looking at
you and they're going wow that is
impressive Kelley now how did you do
that what are this keys well fortunately
in about a month from now I'm going to
be leading my first Financial Peace
University oh wow at church and so I be
if they when I tell them I was coming
they're like wow how'd you do that I was
like well I'm gonna be leading this
class you can come and find out ah so
what do you expose to getting out of
that what do you think was your key for
me I just had to be really I'm not a
very detail-oriented person unless I
really get focused so for me I needed a
little Gary if you're an air traffic
controller okay it's true I'm good I'm
gonna work okay yeah you just you can do
that okay all right I got you okay but
in the rest of everything else I'm just
you know I was
I was doing the math constantly I was
like okay how much closer am i how much
closer am I so there was there was that
no seeing the progress was important to
you right very important and then there
was another guy at work who was coming
up on retirement who had also done well
for himself or whatever so I would
constantly go to him and be like this is
what's happening this is what's
happening and he was like your
cheerleader yeah yeah he was like oh
that's good for you and he would always
ask about my net worth I'm like I don't
care right now
I just what I'm looking at the negative
going back towards him you know I'm
trying to get I'm trying to not be
subterranean to start right very cool
good for you
well congratulations very well done what
was the hardest part of this for you um
keeping the foot on the gas especially
during this summer mmm because you know
I like to go places yeah okay very cool
good for you well it's summer and you're
in Nashville there you know I like it
all right Kelly from Madison Wisconsin
fifty-two thousand dollars paid off in
23 months making sixty in year count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one I'm debt free
way to go way to go way to go I love it
I love it I love it very well done
you